we're having Mickey gall on his podcast
you're having we are having him I won't
be here because if you ever think listen
if you ever [ __ ] think right then I'm
gonna betray erich koch from the UFC you
got another thing [ __ ] coming okay
he's my [ __ ] fire team teammate and
I'm not gonna betray his heart okay now
give me the question on open bars with
Bobby hello hey guys I've got an unusual
problem I don't know who else to ask
I've really got a girlfriend my first
one and I'm 30 years old and we started
sleeping together stop next one
sleeping together if I can't seem to
maintain an erection with her oh I love
this one I think this could be because I
[ __ ] over 300 prostitute killings it's
legal and regulated where I live and now
I think I'm just used to a different
kind of sexual experience I feel really
bad because my girlfriend thinks it's
her fault and it's not and I can't tell
her the truth about why I'm having these
troubles I've stopped [ __ ]
prostitutes obviously because I love my
girlfriend but just to test things out
with me I got a rub-and-tug massage the
other day and everything worked fine is
it because I see her as a potential
mother and not a sex I don't know is
what it is if you have a I have a Rob
Rob I'm just saying there's an Oracle in
Men's Journal okay about porn erectile
dysfunction but I think it applies to
hookers too and it says that the mind
has like a six-month like reset so
basically because I tried it with
Charlie Finn we read the Men's Journal
article and we go let's do it he lasted
about four months I lasted three and a
half weeks and I almost exploded I mean
I got I couldn't do it but I really
believe that he should read the Men's
Journal about it just think he should
give himself six months without sex
rub-and-tug or hookers should he abstain
from
sex with her no he should do this I
think that he should have sex with her
if you can get an erection but for six
months of no pornography no hookers none
of that even jerking off okay if you do
it too long like for like five years you
start [ __ ] kids I mean that's the
reason I believe that priests suppress
yeah it suppressed and they you know
when you have nutsack I mean not I'm nut
juice sperm in your sack for ten years
yeah and it doesn't release I think it
changes it into like some evil [ __ ]
witchcraft well it's actually not I will
that's like I brought up scenes in
movies movies some European movies I
want to answer the question his last
question about not wanting to not
feeling sexually attracted to her
because he sees her as a potential
mother than I love her and I always ask
myself this and I do feel it even when
my relationship with him once I get into
the role of feeling like a mom when I
cook when I nurture when I feed the cats
the dog I take care of his day-to-day
stuff I do feel less sexual I feel tied
down by by you know my daily
responsibilities but I don't know I
don't feel that like sexual edge about
me and maybe he he my partner feels that
too but then I don't know I always ask
Mike one can answer this question for me
can I be a mother and a lover can you
see me as both or can you only see me as
one as a one or the other like you can't
like it for instance when you can you
have sex with me knowing that I'm the
mother to your children versus just
seeing me as a sexual object I think it
there's something there's a switch there
with men I don't know how else better to
explain it then I don't it's hard to be
both to a man
it's hard even for me I don't want to
have sex when I've done everything for
him that day I feel like I'm taking on
that role of like nurturer and I don't
want
I don't feel sexual maybe it just is me
I don't know if I'm making any sense but
if anybody has similar experiences or
feelings let me know yes I ordered your
food earlier this is a steak salad thing
I just need something like a pizza or
something I will order you for kind of
pizza can I get you think fry no um
garage that's the only one it's good but
I can't eat it twice so well you have to
get the big one like that with the
ricotta cheese yeah I get that you get
that for me I can get that for you then
you guys will have sex Lee come see me
at levity live in Oxnard um and you will
yeah okay are you mad at me I'm not mad
at you you just have bad manners when
you just know yeah why because when you
only want to hear yourself talk with
anyone George or Gilbert or anybody else
wants to talk okay I want to just like
you know what you don't want to
participate in anybody else's opinions
but yours you love to hear yourself
that's okay
oh you're the captain let's kiss
so Bobby show us another stop I'm gonna
resolve this right now when you were
talking I wasn't everything you were
saying but I just thought it would be
funny if I said because you were talking
about you doing things for me and all
that stuff that that would be funny if
you said if I said you know or i'ma say
that you order me some food I don't
really want you to worry for I would
just I would you know oh you would have
you made it a bit yeah and so now you
made it real and now it's weird yeah it
is weird now why would you make a bit
out of that I really was gonna order you
pizza wookie can you if you that's how
you do it he gets you double twice kylo
and that's gonna be your husband
that's gonna be your husband
unfortunately I accept Lord God I accept
my fate Wow
[Music]